-Our first guest tonight i
Tony- and Academy Award-winnin
actress who you know from film
like "Chicago" and "Traffic.
She stars in the series
"Prodigal Son,"
which airs Tuesday nights
on Fox.
Please welcome back to the sho
Catherine Zeta-Jones.
Hello, Catherine.
How are you?
-I'm good, Seth.
It's so lovely to see you.
It's been a while.
-It has been awhile.
It's always a delight
to see you.
How have you and your family
been holding up?
-Pretty good, you know?
I mean, it's been
an unprecedented year
for everybody.
I must say, personally,
it was lovely
when we were in a vulnerable
and unknowing time
to have my peeps,
my loved ones around.
So, I had my son home
from college
and my daughter home
from school.
She goes to school
in Switzerland.
So, we were all back
in our bubble.
And supposedly,
speaking to my son,
we fared better
than many families.
He's like, "Mom,
you don't understand --
people aren't talking
to each other."
They're like, "No."
So, we played lots of games.
My kids -- and I must say,
kudos to them.
I thought for sure, you know
they're all back --
not just them, but all their
other friends from high school
all live down our street, right?
They were brought up right her
all together.
And I thought it was gonna b
party central.
You know, all these kids
coming back from college,
congregating in
the garage band garage,
which is usually ours.
But they really got it.
So, we had a good time.
And they're finishing up now and
looking forward to, hopefully,
a more kind of outdoorsy summe
than we had last year.
-Well, that is a credit to them.
Did you feel a sympathy
for the fact that, you know,
they were young people who were,
in your son's case,
losing a year
of in-person college?
-Yeah.
I live vicariously
through my kids.
Let me tell you.
I never went to college.
I was schlepping the board
of London and that,
touring "The Pajama Game"
at 15 --
jazz hands, jazz hands,
jazz hands.
You know, so there is
a part of me that --
I mean, I had an education
but I self-educated myself in my
love for learning, you know.
And so my kids -- who got
all their brains from me,
but don't tell Michael.
You know? I mean...
-You -- I just read
a wonderful article.
I didn't quite appreciate
how young you started.
You mentioned your early
schlepping across the boards
So, you knew
at a very young age,
as soon as you got
a taste of it,
that this would be
what you were gonna do.
-Yeah, I was --
They did this big publicit
stunt in Britain
looking for kids for "Annie,
and then subsequently,
Micky Dolenz's directorial
"Bugsy Malone" onstage.
Right?
So they came to Wales, they...
You know, they went down
to my --
Where I live in Wales
is the end of the track.
You can't go further west
unless you get the Cork ferr
over to Ireland, you know?
So they came down in a publicity
stunt, basically.
And so me, who had aspirations
and was in dance school
at the church hall down th
street, you know,
auditioned and I got it.
And that was the spark,
you know, that got me into
this amazing -- I'm humbly
grateful -- business
where it's just taken me
on this wild journey.
But my kids who are in college
who I live vicariously through
you know, it's like, they can'
do what they're supposed to do
You know, it's like...
It's like, I used to say to my
kids, you know,
if they called me on a Saturda
morning, if it was early,
I'd go, "why are you still -
why are you awake?
Shouldn't you be, like,
sleeping?
What time did you get home
last night?"
"Oh, I was in bed by 10:00."
"Are you crazy?!"
[ Laughter ]
"You worked so hard throug
the week and you're in bed?!
What's wrong with you?
What's wrong with you, son?"
So anyway, they do --
they love learning and
they're having a great time.
But I kind of lost
that part of my life.
Not that I'm complaining, 'cause
I wouldn't be speaking to you,
which I always love to do.
So, I love to see them be
teenagers and just, you know
and excited to see where
their journey takes them.
You know, they both
love learning,
but they both are very goo
young actors.
They've never done anythin
professional
or anything like that,
but as actors,
both my husband and I, Michael
you know, we...
there are so many other
professions
that we'd like them to be in
But it's very, very clear
that they've got
that fire in their belly.
And for me, it's like,
"Party on, guys,"
because it's just taken me
on a great journey.
But I was never the son of
Spartacus like Michael was
-Sure, yeah.
-And that's a different
kettle of fish.
That's a different bear,
babe, you know?
And so even with that,
those reservations,
but clearly, Michael had t
prove himself
maybe more than the average bear
because his dad was
Kirk Douglas.
And so, even with that
deterrent,
they're like,
"Nah, still love it."
-Do -- Obviously, they hav
two actors for parents,
but maybe you are the only
accomplished dancer.
I'm not quite sure where Michael
falls on the dancing scale
But I'm gonna say
it's safe to say
you're the better of the two
-Did you ever see the video?
♪♪ When the going gets tough
That's as good as it gets, babe.
It's like, he can click
in time to the beat.
Every now and again,
he gets off course.
But he's a great actor.
Michael always says that
when you're dancing,
"Always look at me
from the waist up."
Because he can do the...
but the feet...
-I believe, if my memory serves,
you're talking about the video
to "Romancing the Stone."
The Billy Ocean music video.
-Yeah.
Billy Ocean, yeah.
Michael's pop video.
He's very proud of that.
It's funny how actors --
It's funny how actors, like,
for me it's like...
I sing and dance
and all that stuff,
but there's a part that wants me
to be the female Bono.
You know, to go out there
in leather pants,
my glasses on, and rock it
at a stadium, you know.
And so, for Michael,
it's just always like,
"Yeah, that was my --
when I did my music video.
-The best is while you wer
saying it, I thought,
"That sounds crazy,
what you're talking about.
And then I realize, "Oh, no --
that's a video
I saw 100,000 times."
-Yeah. Oh, yeah.
♪♪ When the going gets tough
-So, let him know
it stayed with me.